as we have witnessed over the last days
weeks months but also because Russia is
actively manipulating the gas market
I'm deeply convinced that without Unity
our determination our solidarity
we will prevail
and we have over the last six months
during this war
very much increased our preparedness and
we have weakened the grip that Russia
had on our economy and our continent
we've done three things as you recall
the first one was demand reduction
demand reduction so save gas in order to
save it to the storage we've created a
joint starch and this is really a
success story because now we are already
at 82 percent with the joint storage in
Europe as you know our goal was to reach
80 at the end of October so we overshoot
and that's good
the Second Step that we've taken was
diversify away from Russian fossil fuels
and you know we have stopped the Russian
coal the import of Russian coal we are
winding down the Russian oil and we've
been working very hard
to diversify away from Russia towards
other reliable suppliers like for
example of the United States or Norway
Azerbaijan Algeria and others
actually today Norway is delivering more
gas to the European Union than Russia
and we were able if you look at the cuts
that Russia has done in gas we were able
to completely compensate so far the gas
Imports through other reliable suppliers
and of course the third step is the most
important this is massive investment and
Renewables
we have repower EU on the table
the Renewables are cheap they are
homegrown they make us independent
we will deploy renewable new Renewables
this year that aren't equivalent to
around about 8 billion cubic meters
so the Renewables are really our energy
insurance for the future
but we also see that the Russian
manipulation of the gas market
has spilled over effects on the
electricity Market
so there's on one hand the Russian
manipulation but there are also other
factors during this summer
we see the effects of climate change
we see the drought there's a drought
hydropower has been reduced by 26
percent in the European Union and if you
look at Portugal 46 percent
and we have the fact that we have less
nuclear electricity in the European
Union at the moment being
and this is the reason why we are now
confronted with astronomic electricity
prices for households and companies and
with an enormous Market volatility
therefore we will put forward a set of
five different immediate measures
the first one is
smart saving of electricity
what has changed over the summer because
of the elements I was just mentioning
that we see there's a global scarcity of
energy
so whatever we do one thing is for sure
we have to save electricity but we have
to save it in a smart way
if you look at the costs of electricity
there are Peak demands
and this is what is expensive because in
these Peak demands
the expensive gas comes into the market
so what we have to do is flatten the
Curve and avoid the peak demands we will
propose a mandatory Target for reducing
electricity use at peak hours and we
will work very closely with the member
states to achieve this
the second measure
we will propose a cap
on the revenues of companies that are
producing electricity with low costs
the low carbon energy sources
are making in these times because they
have low costs but they are high prices
on the market
enormous revenues
revenues they never calculated with
revenues they never dreamed of
and revenues they cannot reinvest as far
these revenues do not reflect their
production costs
so it is now time for the consumers
to benefit from the low costs of low
carbon sources like for example the
Renewables we will propose to re-channel
these unexpected profits
we Channel them to the member states so
that the member states can support the
vulnerable households and vulnerable
companies
the third measure is
that the same goes of course for the
unexpected profits of fossil fuel
companies
oil and gas companies have also made
massive profits and therefore we will
propose that there is a solidarity
contribution for fossil fuel companies
because all energy sources must help to
overcome this crisis
member states should invest these
revenues to as I said support vulnerable
households and vulnerable companies but
also to invest them in clean homegrown
energy sources as the Renewables are for
example
the fourth point is addressing the
energy utility companies
that must be supported to be able to
cope with the volatility of the markets
and here it is a problem of securing
future markets and for that liquidity is
needed
these companies are currently being
requested to provide unexpected large
amounts of funds now
who threatens their capacity not only to
trade
but also the stability of the future
markets
it is a liquidity problem
therefore we will help to facilitate the
liquidity support by member states for
energy companies
we will update our temporary framework
and enable thus State guarantees to be
delivered rapidly
the fifth and the last point
we aim at lowering the costs of gas
and therefore we will propose a price
cup
on Russian gas
of course the objective is here very
clear
we all know that our sanctions are
deeply grinding into the Russian economy
with a heavy negative impact
but Putin is partially buffering through
fossil fuel revenues so here the
objective is we must cut Russia's
revenues which Putin users to finance
his atrocious war in Ukraine and now our
work of the last month really pays off
because at the beginning of the warm if
you looked at the imported gas
40 of it
was Russian gas since a long time
today we're down to nine percent only
so these are the five measures we will
discuss with the member states at the
informal Council energy Minister Council
on Friday
these are tough times
and they are not over soon
but I'm deeply convinced that if we show
the solidarity the unity and we have the
determination for that we have the
economic strength we have the political
will that we shall overcome thank you
thank you very much the president will
now take a few questions please let me
know if you are interested Marcus
um you can walk over to the mic oh yeah
seems to work
um if I made a question in German
okay
um actually three
um
blanket
this is
foreign
thank you
um second question Francesca go ahead
it's fine
Mr president if the introduction of a
price Cup on Russian gas has become
urgent uh one will you really uh
introduce it considering that some
member states
apparently are skeptical still skeptical
and the price could be 100 euros
acceptable or you are talking thinking
about something different thank you
that's internet
I answer first of all a bit in German
and then of course I no no and then I
will answer your question uh again it's
about the Russian prize cap and how fast
we are able to move
um
foreign
[Music]
now sorry
um so uh the price cap on Russian gas
can go really fast and that is important
we have worked very hard over the last
month
to make sure that we have the solidarity
net that is important for the member
states that we can make sure that the
gas flows where it's needed most
and this work was necessary also to have
other suppliers to provide us with
necessary gas
so that we cannot be blackmailed anymore
by putins or Russia's announcement what
gas is concerned you have seen that over
the last month he always tried to
Blackmail his as I've just said 13
member states have been partially or
totally cut off the Russian gas already
so we don't give anything any more on
these announcements by Russia because
they we know they are blackmailing us
the best thing is to fortify yourselves
and go towards other suppliers and have
solidarity
so one more question please
[Music]
Rob
um
you've mentioned the price cap on
Russian gas but why not having a price
cap on other gas LNG for example uh
maybe a flexible kind of cap but this
gas is also very expensive yeah
yeah point
indeed this is on the table
and we're looking at that too
and here again
um excuse me if I repeat myself but it's
important overall energy globally is
scarce and of course LNG gas can be
re-rooted in their ship's deliveries to
different regions of the world
so what we are looking at now is that we
stay competitive
for the LNG suppliers
but we make sure
that other prices we pay are not
extraordinarily high but in a decent
range and therefore we're looking at
that too this is on the table
thank you very much that concludes our
press Point all right thank you stay
tuned for the college readout